we've seen the rise of Andrew Tate
why do you think he's become such a huge
figure to young men and boys in
particular and what impact is that
having amongst women of your generation
I think for boys they're hearing the
same messages over and over again which
is obviously the
kind of demonizing masculinity saying
you need to become more sensitive you
need to be almost more like women in the
way that you think about things and
approach things and I think
you know men tend to just process their
emotions differently and think about
things differently you know it doesn't
make us make them wrong but I think now
we're almost
telling men that all of the ways they do
it are toxic or um too blunt or so
they're trying to kind of become more
feminine and so I think someone like
Andrew Tate comes along and he has a
masculine approach to it quite
heavy-handed and a bit blunt but
I think for men that's appealing because
it's the same with girls you know
they're being lied to quite often and
kind of convinced that there's something
wrong with them
and then you have someone come along and
say oh well
if you have these masculine traits and
it's a good thing you can be strong you
can do this whatever
um so I can see why that's appealing and
I think
yeah I think yeah yeah well it makes
sense and I said it at the time what I
find very puzzling although it's not
puzzling I think the answer is quite
obvious it's like whenever anyone comes
along who uh Taps into that frustration
that young men feel about like this is
how I am but I'm being told that the way
that I am is wrong right whether it's a
Jordan Peterson or an Andrew Tate who
who I have my reservations about no one
ever goes why is that no one ever goes
like why why am I doing this yeah what
are they lacking exactly they're filling
a vacuum yeah I don't know I think
yeah it's just we hear the same messages
over and over again and when someone has
something different to say it's really
appealing
um and there's there's probably stuff
within what he's saying that is useful
that boys should be listening to but we
kind of need to
listen as well and figure out what that
is I think Andrew Tate is a very good
example of what happens when there are
not enough healthy Role Models yeah so
someone who is as out there as he is
will come along and Hoover up their
attention because no one else is
speaking to that audience and they give
people
guidelines to follow like he'll say this
is what you need to do to be a man and
then they've kind of got markers to
check off whereas you know we're living
in these consumer cultures without you
know the decline of religion and things
like that we don't have those set
guidelines of how to come of age what
gives us purpose what we should be
following so when someone comes along
and says oh this is how you live a
happier life things like that then
people are going to listen and as well
when you think about the fact that the
divorce rate is what it is a lot of boys
are growing up there's no male figure in
the household they go to school most of
their teachers are women they're
surrounded by women education has become
more and more feminized so traditional
male behavioral types like
boisterousness you know but wanting to
be physically active uh actively look
down upon then someone comes in to give
what in their eyes is a positive vision
of masculinity why wouldn't they follow
it yeah and I wrote a piece about um how
the kind of social justice activism
culture today is very feminine in nature
so things like cancer culture women are
more likely to use indirect methods of
aggression like reputation destruction
social exclusion you know we're more
likely to be risk-averse so safetyism is
kind of parallels you know typical
female Behavior
and I think a lot of this stuff that's
happening in culture is feminine in
nature
and some boys and men don't feel like
they fit into that they don't that's not
how
um they would have Society be and you
know it's not because they're wrong
um and I think yeah so someone masculine
comes along it's very attractive to them
because it probably aligns more with
their traits than the culture now and
the other thing that I find worrying is
so he's imprisoned nobody knows if he's
guilty or innocent
and but people think right okay that's
it the problem is dealt with we've got
rid of him and I'm there thinking well
no the problem isn't dealt with because
then somebody else is going to come
along and tap into it yeah maybe worse
yeah exactly yeah it's true I think we
yeah like you said there's a vacuum
there there's some someone they're
feeling a demand for something
um so we need to figure out what what
that demand is for and and try and
figure out what it is within that
kind of ultra masculine front that
someone like Angie Tate has what is it
that they find attractive about that
like because there is value in it surely
there is if so many people are
interested in it well there's definitely
value in it in the sense that he you
know if you're telling people to take
response men men particularly to take
responsibility to pursue their dreams
these these are things that a lot of men
of your generation never heard in their
lives they've never been encouraged
um but then you know as I said I think
someone who says this you should only
see your children once a year or
whatever it's probably gone in the wrong
direction there so that's why I say
healthy role models and uh you know I
think that's why Jordan Peterson
actually became as big as he became
because he was like take responsibility
here's some rules you know yeah
um and I I think I think that it's
important for people like that to be
coming through yeah and giving positive
uh visions of masculinity and for
society to stop demonizing yeah and I
think that's what men respond empty
they've responded to the kind of pick
yourself up and sort yourself out girls
don't really respond to that in the same
way you know we we need a different
approach
um and I think boys don't really have
that in society it's all about like
you're doing fine you're you know relax
de-stress take on less challenges
whereas a lot of boys mental health
problems might come from the fact that
they're not being pushed maybe they want
to be pushed they want to take on more
challenges
um so I think when someone comes along
using that male approach is really
appealing to them
foreign